but we start with breaking news with
traffic nathan tannenbaum in the 80s now
traffic center most of the freeways are
in good shape but we have a really big
problem northbound i-15 has been closed
by the nevada highway patrol at lake
mead there's police activity both on the
freeway over lake mead and on lake mead
underneath the freeway let me show you
what we're talking about here there's a
big line of nhp troopers lined up on the
right shoulder so that's downtown las
vegas this is the northbound side of the
i-15 traffic is being diverted off
northbound i-15 at lake mead and even
further back they're stopping folks just
out of the spaghetti bowl so this is
northbound i-15 they're trying to get
folks off the northbound side of the
freeway at the washington d street exit
in the meantime the freeway is backing
up pretty big time before the spaghetti
bowl we're going to keep an eye on this
for you as soon as we find out more
about exactly what's going on and when
i-15 reopens but for now you cannot go
northbound on i-15 at lake mead